right an awful lot to talk about five
minutes to do it in let's go
so hi welcome to week one of ox log
Hillary term 2013 this is a project
where I make weekly videos about my
experiences being a student at Boston
University
the point of which is to try and inform
students who are thinking of applying to
University to Oxford specifically about
the reality of student life to try and
dispel any misconceptions they may have
about the university however I'm not the
only youtuber that does this kind of
thing in Oxford this term I'm going to
be joined by another youtuber Jamie
Mills who's a second year PPE student at
modeling college he's gonna be uploading
videos every Thursday about his
experiences on weekly basis being a
student so if you haven't already
subscribed to his channel do he's done a
fantastic series of videos about
applying to Oxford step-by-step in your
application right the way from applying
and choosing which college to apply to
to the interview to the result so be
sure to subscribe to his channel I'm
really quite excited about this project
this is gonna be good now if you've
watched any of my videos before you
probably noticed that I'm using a
different camera than normal this camera
is a GoPro it's a camera which the
college bought in order to do stuff with
their sports teams I borrowed it for
this weekend because of the big thing
which happened this week which was it
snowed like quite a lot so Oxford is a
place that's renowned for being really
pretty and Oxford in the snow is just
absolutely astonishing Peters is looking
gorgeous at the moment and I borrowed
the GoPro to go to University parks
these guys are building an igloo people
having snowball fights and just
generally it's been really really nice I
also stumbled across an impressive level
of dedication from my new favorite
varsity sports team I'm not making this
up this is the Oxford University
Quidditch team playing a match
however despite any meteorological
conditions work has to go on so this
week I've been carrying on in the theory
option with canonical quantization of
classical fields into quantum field
theory while we now miss Ferrett physics
I've been looking at inverse methods
when you look at a map of the earth and
you see a temperature profile for the
whole earth or wind speed whatever it
may be that's been taken from a sock
like you haven't gone all the way around
the earth and put the thermometer in the
ground for example and got reading of
the temperature for everywhere what
you've done is you've got an instrument
on the satellite which takes a reading
from space and it takes a measurement
that from and from that measurement you
infer what the temperature is Beth's
inverse methods and the real kicker when
it comes to is trying to keep track with
the errors which propagate through the
months so this is the part of the course
which is really practically and this is
aimed at if you're going to go into
science this is the kind of
bread-and-butter thing you're going to
be doing you want to design an
instrument for a satellite that's going
to go up to space you need to be able to
show how good that instrument is going
to be with error bounds this week is
also notable because it's marked the
start of my Master's project so as I
talked about last week my Master's
projects are quite large part my degree
and I'm doing my Master's project you
know it's very physics specifically I'm
looking at stochastic processes in
climate modeling I will be talking about
this in future videos don't worry
oh five minutes really is not that long
at all so last week I chickened out of
it and I didn't really fulfill my
promise of looking at something
specifically oxford so this week I jump
right into the big league and I went to
the Bodley and library now Bob din
libraries is a collection of 40
libraries which services all of the
University of Oxford what I went to was
the old bottom which is the central
library really in the whole network and
was founded in 16 - by Thomas oddly I
like going to where there because it's
utterly utterly silent like in Peters
college library you could be forgiven
for you know rustling a sweet wrapper or
you know you're answering your phone as
you walk out you would be crucified if
you did that in the volume plus as you
can see from the footage like it's a
really really beautiful building and
it's a legal deposit library which means
it's entitled to a copy of every book
which is published in the UK in fact
it's collections grow at a rate of 5,000
books per week I think it last County
had like 12 million books or something
like that and the includes really rare
and precious things like that the order
of the Magna Carta and Newton's
Principia and Shakespeare's First Folio
last but not least the question for you
guys
so last week it was so great to hear
from so many of you it was really nice
to see you guys talking to each other
and answering each other's questions not
least because it saves me a job but just
to let you know that there are other
people in the same situation and that
I really hope the segment would do well
it's also interesting is the fact that
there are a lot of people who either at
Oxford or at university currently so
I've got to practice this week for
people who are at the University at the
moment please comment with the one bit
of advice that you'd like to give to
people who are about to apply to
university that you'd wish you've been
told when you were applying people who
haven't yet applied to University is
there anywhere in Oxford that you'd like
me to cover the might have heard of
somewhere like the Ashmolean or mattress
Museum or the physics faculty or
whatever let me know if there's any way
that you'd like me to cover and I will
do my best to go there and not
forgetting Jamie welcome to the project
really looking forward to video on
Thursday and hearing what you've been
getting up to
I passed the baton over to you